so it's really a great pleasure to be in
this
in this workshop uh all the experts are
here and i'm not really working in this
area most of my time so it's great to
have some of the expert at least
listening to what you have to say so
please feel free to comment and
interrupt and so on and so forth and you
know that's the major theme of my work
and we'd be very happy to hear any
comments that you may have on this work
uh
and i'm also apologizing i missed some
of your talks i'm teaching a course with
450 students this semester so somehow
you know i have to buy them things
so i'm in statistics department i also
in the cs department and i want to do
legal statistics with lego as i mean in
the sense of the 1920s or the 1930s so
what do i mean by that
i want ethereums which have error bounds
and find on finite samples like you do
when you try to sum to to estimate the
bias of a coin
i want algorithms that you know i can
say that they terminate and when do they
terminate and what do they output
ideally this is not so much the approach
of the of the 1912 1920s and the 1930s
it's more the modern approach ideally
you would like robustness under the
modeling assumption so this is a very
difficult problem and i'm not going to
say anything about it but you know
ideally this is what we would all want
right and we don't necessarily have that
and today i'm going to talk about two
initial steps in in the area
in areas related to population genetics
for simple or two maybe oversimplified
models
and both of these workers sort of works
in progress one of them is on the
archive but i
don't want to declare it finished yet
and the other one is not even on the
archive so you will see it
okay so i'm just going to say what the
two works are one is just something that
we just put on the archive so can one
hear the shape of population history so
this should sound familiar to many of
you
and the other one is the
optimal influence of incomplete lineage
sorting or in in complete lineage
sorting
so what i'm going to talk about first
i'm going to talk about this question
which is can one hear the shape of
population history and i'm only going to
talk about population size even though
we have grand vision of how to solve the
more general problem which involves the
migration and so on and so forth so this
joint focus union came from japan
and mickey
was sitting in the room somewhere mickey
arts from uc berkeley and nathan also
was a postdoc here and now he's at
melbourne
so yeah it's it's like preaching to the
converted i don't think there's any
point of even putting this light so we
all want to
infer past population size and you know
this this of course
has interest beyond population and
genetics
uh you want to study species out of the
human
and it's really interesting to study the
size and the history so we know that so
now i'm going to try to offend the
minimal number of people including the
minimal number of people sitting in the
room right so we have a lot of work in
this area many of many of the volunteers
is in this room
so
uh sort of if you want a very very rough
partition of the kind of of information
that you're using you can use use
information about the coalescence
coalescence time and maybe a famous
paper is the favorites of of the paper
of lee and darby
a couple of years ago that uh
essentially tried to recover population
history from one haplotype
and uh there's a lot of work both
theoretical and and
an empirical work on using a little
spectrum
so um
in particular i don't want to get into
the discussion theoretical discussion
which is really interesting so there's
these papers of miles ferman and
patterson which says that you cannot
actually recover even the population a
size history from the alien frequency
but maybe you can under some assumptions
and so on and so forth so there are
various people including in this room
will study this problem extensively
extensively i'm not going to talk about
that and then you can look at other kind
of data which is sort of blends of
sequences that are common and again
there's there's very nice work for
instance of a
ras museum at berkeley and others using
this kind of information so this is for
me
i mean i i don't want to offend anybody
but for me it's all of this work is you
know maybe except of the uh
work of a milestone in patterson and the
reply to this work which are theoretical
the rest of this work i would call
empirical work right because really we
don't really have very strong statement
about you know
how certain are we of what we know in
the sense of theorems
any questions or comments so far
okay
okay so i'm going to use i'm going to
use the the model of population that i'm
going to use in this first part we're
going to talk about this the history of
the size of the population and i'm going
to use kingsman coalescent
so uh
what we'll be interested in in
particular is the trade-off between the
amount of information that we have and
i'm going to talk about which
information
soon
and the accuracy of the reconstruction
of the history
so i don't know if there's any point of
uh
introducing the right fisherman or the
kingsman coalescence model in this
workshop but i'll flash the slides
anyways just so that you can look at
them and and then i'll talk a little bit
about what we know about that
okay
so this is what i do for my students in
the situations like that detect the typo
in this slide okay so any typos it all
looks okay right this is the standard
right fisher that we know
of course from the probabilistic point
of view the one feature that's important
here is that the chance that we have
more than two
more than two guys coalescing in one
generation is is of order one over n
squared so we can neglect it so we can
just talk about coalitions of pearls
and when we take the limit as n goes to
infinity
what we get is we get kingsman
coalescent
so this is a continuous time process
where we go we go back in time from the
present day to the history
and we know that the time for
coalescence when we talk about constant
population size we have this random
variables
that have exponential distribution this
parameter k choose 2 will case the
number of individuals that we're looking
at
okay everybody is very bold
very good okay
so now let's make it slightly more
interesting
now we're going to look at variable
population size so it's the same setup
but the population size is changing and
the basic assumption here
is that the population is well mixed at
all times so we want to apply the same
variant of the life visual model or the
king kingdom and coalescence model to
the setup
so what happens is that what what we
have now is we have a random variable
that
at time t
the rate of coalescence is exactly going
to be the same we also saw it in other
talks like steve stock yesterday the the
rate of coalescence at time t is going
to be essentially what it should be k
choose 2 but you have to to normalize by
the ratio of the initial population size
to the to the current population size
because the time is always measured in
terms of we are not doing any time
change the time is always measured in
terms of the initial population that
we're looking at
that's the setup that we're looking at
okay so here's the setup uh we have a
well mixed population we have this
function that determines the size at
each time
and okay now
this is the point where i hope that
you're going to shout at me so please
shout at me after i say what the
assumption is so we are going to make a
very simplified assumption here and the
assumption is that we are going to have
a lot
of coalescence times of pairs of
individuals and their assumption is that
they're going to be iid okay so they're
going to be independent and identically
distributed
and
this set i'm going to call t1 to tl so
of course
if you're not going to jump at me let me
jump at myself but the obvious question
is where do you get this form
and my answer is that we don't really
know where to get this form we know how
to partition the dna into blocks and if
the blocks actually correspond to
different genealogies we can do that but
of course partitioning them into blocks
in an intelligent way it's not something
that we know how to do but still this is
the assumption that we're going to make
and maybe one
direction for
future research if we want to look at it
if we want to do some something
empirical you can think about working in
a setup where
you guys provide some software that look
at the dna and breaks it into pieces and
says these are the pieces that
correspond to different times we don't
integrate over this huge space of you
know the coalescence and and and and all
of the history you were just doing some
simple statistical method to break it
down into pieces and then we are going
to apply some simpler algorithm in order
to find out what the history is so it's
not clear if that's something worthwhile
considering or not but that's that's the
setup that we're going to imagine that
we write
i think i say something you know
criticize the the word in orange or
something
you don't like the orange i i know i
thought that was that was what you were
gonna oh no no right so no the other one
yeah you can also jump but this is a
very legitimate i'm throwing a lot of
information away right so in some sense
i'm working in a situation where say i
have just two individuals or one in one
individuals and i'm looking at the two
copies right so but you know for me this
is very initial very aspects of these
projects are very very initial still the
amount of pain that we had in order to
derive this result was enough for us to
decide that we stopped for now right but
you know as you see the results are
pretty simple
okay so what is the distribution uh
what is the distribution of the
what is the distribution of the
coalescence time so this again this is
something that we essentially saw at
other talks before including steve's
talk yesterday so the probability that
the coalescence time is less than the
number capital t
is given by this beautiful formula so
instead of a simple exponential we have
exponential with the integral of a and
zero over and t
and what is the goal well the goal is to
estimate the population history the size
and t from the sample to samples d1 to
tier
okay so
we all good
okay very boring okay so now i'm going
to continue doing something very very
simple
i'm just going to do the simplest idea
that a frequent test would do at the
beginning of the 20th century i'm going
to divide the time into intervals i want
to ik
and i'm just going to count the data
point in each interval the number of
coalescence in each interval of time so
that's what i'm going to do
so let's look at what the estimate is
what the estimate is actually so
a
hat xk is going to be the fraction of
coalescence that i'm going to have at
the case interval
and hat sk is going to be the number of
all core lessons up to interval number k
and i'm going back in time
and here's the beautiful estimate so
maybe you're used to this kind of
elegant formulas but i'm not so used to
it so let's go over it slowly so what
you get you get that the estimate is
going to be the direction between the
population at interval k
and the initial population is going to
be the length of the interval divided by
minus log one minus this hat x k over
one minus hat s k minus one
so why are we why why are we using this
estimate i don't know if this is going
to help you but the expression that's
written on the on the bottom on on in
the middle equation is exactly the
empirical conditional distribution that
we call less at time at interval k given
the fact that we haven't coalesced so
far
so the thing that n hat k is estimating
is what the average of the population we
get we'll get to that in a second right
so we have to obviously i want to you
know especially again again if you can
refer back to your talk yesterday i want
to improve the poor estimate something
that's very continuous but i i break it
into discrete intervals so i have to say
what i'm actually going to estimate
we'll get to that in a second right so
okay so again what's what's the reason
for doing that right so
if you're very bored and you want to do
algebra in the middle of a talk what
we're actually doing is we're inverting
this equation over here
so if you ask what's the probability
that
the what's the probability that we
coalesce interval interval k well it's
the probability that we haven't
coalesced up to interval k
and then we just use the formula that
we've seen before so we move this
conditioning over here we get this
equation we move the one to the other
side we take the log and we get the
equation that we have
okay it's just very simple
everything i'm doing is very very simple
right it doesn't i don't do it it's too
early in the morning to do anything
complicated
so it's the sort of thing that people in
survival analysis if they're wanting to
estimate hazard rates right
right so yeah the difference with the
kind of stuff that's usually done in
survival survival analysis is that the
people are looking for something smooth
and the estimates are you know in terms
of the smoothness of what you want to
estimate we are not we are just going to
ignore it and maybe it's this is a very
good comment because in the the setup of
survival analysis it does actually make
sense to talk about smooth functions
that we want to estimate while in the
setup of population genetics we are
interested specifically in events where
you know the population can jump very
quickly right so maybe this assumption
is not a very reasonable assumption so
one of the reasons that we're doing
we're doing derivation that are somewhat
similar to the derivation in in survival
analysis is that you want to consider a
different setup where population can
jump in a way right so and we'll get to
that to the exact statements in a second
okay
so
we can provide a
confidence interval just by using large
deviational chain of bounds so let me
tell you what this bonds will tell you
so first of all we have to decide what
is it that we're estimating at each
interval
and the actual number that we're
estimating and
this is maybe a very poor choice of name
is what we call the effective population
size at interval k and the effective
population says that interval k is this
expression
if the population size is constant it's
actually going to give us the population
size if it's not constant it's somehow
measuring
something that's related to the rate of
coalescence in the in the in the
interval which if the population size
was constant would be given by the by
this number right so that's the best
that we can do somehow
okay so that's what we're actually going
to estimate and if you want to say what
is there all right so the arrow composed
of two terms so this is the error that
ideally would want to measure the order
that ideally want to measure would want
to to measure
the maximal possible difference between
the population size at interval that the
interval that we're looking at and what
we estimated
that's what we would ideally want to
measure and of course this error is it
comes in as a sum of two errors one of
them has to do
with how non-constant the population
size is so the l1 the arrow for interval
k of type one is just the supremum of
the difference between the actual log of
the population size and the log of this
quantity that we're estimating and the
others the other term is the estimation
error so what is the difference between
what we estimated the quantity with the
tilde and
and what we
what we call the effective population
size in the intervals
on people who don't like equations
maybe you're not in the room
right yeah so yeah so very good so
that's a very good comment so this error
can be very large and to some extent one
once i've decided to partition the time
into little intervals there's nothing i
can do about it right you know it could
be that you know there's some very very
crazy ship that's going on in this
interval and once i've decided to bucket
the interval to that interval there's
nothing i can do about this so this
error there's essentially no way for me
to bound except if i'm making some
assumptions okay so you know the
smoothness assumptions how many jumps
and so on and so forth so in order to
bound this term i have to say oh if i
make this and that assumption then i can
say that this quantity is small right
but i cannot do anything other than that
because indeed you know the popular if
the population is crazy enough there's
nothing i can say about this quantity so
we will concentrate on the other
quantity which is the quantity which is
related to the stats right so this is by
once i decided to partition into the
intervals you know this quantity is just
out there and only but the only bars i
can derive on this i obtained when i
make some assumptions about variations
of the populations very good
except you can choose the sizes of your
intervals say again you can choose how
many intervals and have what size right
so but this makes some issues with
dependence which again at this initial
step we don't we don't we don't address
right so that's of course a very good
point we don't address it at this point
okay so let's talk a little bit
let's talk a little bit a little bit
about the estimation and also so this is
this difference between what we think is
the effective population size and the
actual population size so for those of
you who like equations you know this is
the beautiful bound that we get okay so
the probability that the log of the
population size is in this interval
which i shift by log epsilon and zero
again the assumption is that the length
of the interval is epsilon and zero
so the probability that i'm correct
i'm in this range between a and b plus
this number
is this is the form that you get in a
chain of bounds so there's exponentially
small error in c
and what is the interval well the
interval is this beautiful form from a
to b which includes the log of the log
in all kind of minuses to make it very
intuitive okay
so if you don't see immediately what
this is it's a little difficult to see
what it is
uh so let me tell you a little bit about
all of the parameters that are involved
so the most important parameter maybe is
l little l which is the number of uh
pairs that arrived at the interval that
we're looking at right because there
will be a bunch of core lessons until
this interval and then there's the
little l that is the number of
the number of uh guys that arrive to
this to the interval
and then if we look at this quantity
capital l x k over l
this is the fraction of coalescence
inside the interval among all the guys
that haven't coalesced so far right so
this is sort of a natural quantity to
look at and if you'd ask what's the
length of this interval which is maybe
of some interest so if you actually
calculate what's the length of this
interval assuming that l is not too
small
and suppose you want to fix the
confidence level to be five percent
because you like to send your papers to
science and nature which for some reason
believe in five percent then what you'll
get if you fix the confidence level
you'll get that the length of the
interval is of order
one over square with the number of
coalescences that arrive to your
interval and then this quantity
l over lx k which if you think about it
this quantity before taking the minus
one is essentially the length of the
interval of time that you're looking at
so the length of the interval the
conclusion from that is of order one
over the square root of the number of
samples and then the inverse of the
length of the interval in term of in
terms of time
so of course there's some very deep
insights that you all know that comes
from that that is that the deep history
is much harder to recover and short
intervals if i petition too short in the
it's much harder this is the way to
quantify this somehow still you had a
question
okay any questions so far the reason you
need dependencies because you're
applying chinese
yeah of course i mean the reason i need
independence because i applied chinese
so you can apply this and i mean there
are many many future directions that you
can go including not using pairs and so
forth but you know i just do the very
very simple basic vanilla version of the
problem
okay so
uh
this is how it looks like so actually i
mean this is the nice thing about
working with mickey and and nathan they
actually simulate and see what you get
so we actually simulated this process so
what do we have here i mean let's look
at this picture
what we have here the blues are the
actual population size according to
which we generated the data
okay so these are the blue intervals the
little red intervals are estimates
and the
pinkish area is the confidence
confidence regime is 95 percent
confidence okay oh it's five percent
and one of the parameters that we have
here is uh
the number of pairs that we have here is
pretty large so in the top row with
three thousand
that the time intervals corresponds to
five percent of the of the population
size so it's zero point zero five that's
the little intervals that we're
estimating this with three thousand this
will be certified and you see that
you're doing better both in terms of the
actual estimates and in terms of the
error bounds that are a little smaller
in this picture
yes it's a little hard to see when it
jumps from the top to the second blue
line is that in the middle are those is
there a blue line there or is it off in
the junctions you must go to the left of
that sorry
left left left left here
for that right above that point yeah
so here's the just the the model is
the instantaneous jump right in one
generation the population jumped from
whatever size it was to twice the size
and that's where we get the errors is in
that jump period we get out of the year
but we also get errors we also get
errors back in the history right we get
errors in many places but a very natural
place to get an error is when your
interval is not placed exactly before or
after the point where the explosion
happens and then you're going to
estimate something in between right so
that's a very natural place for an order
to take place so here our error is
actually outside the 95 percent
confidence because you know there is
this this huge huge change in population
very good point yeah
that's the difference between the left
and the right
so i think the only difference between
the left and the right is uh
it's just two different histories yeah i
don't think there's anything else i mean
the top is 30 thousand the button is at
the top is 3 000 at the bottom it's
celsius but it's just two different
histories
so the
the bars they're your theoretical these
are the theoretical so if you actually
done multiple simulations to sort of see
right so instead instead we prefer to do
one sample because it already shows that
our bound could be improved if we are
probably more more careful like so
rather than actually figuring out right
yeah but you just look at it and you
know you can improve these bonds right
right so okay so this is of course a
very important question which i'll get
to in a second i actually make a very
strong assumption here that i have the
exact colors this time
okay you provide me with the exact
collection time and i provided this
picture right so it's like of course
because it's very i said it's a very
idealized model and i'm going to talk a
little bit about that i'm going slower
than i wanted okay so here's a how much
time do i have by the way no
my st my estimation posted 20 minutes
okay
yeah
you said you could improve the bounds
but like the intervals where your
confidence interval goes all the way to
the top but i would guess that that's
yeah of course sometimes you cannot
improve the body if there's no
coalescence events you'll okay i won't
use this mode online but you know you're
dead right but nothing you can do right
it's like there's no coalescence coming
into the interval if all of the poses
score less then you know this is why you
have this often you have this one-sided
so this would not improve all of the way
but it would improve in some of this
that's a very good point
it looks like the bottom left
after the second change your estimation
improved
compared to before that
yes
so i i'm not sure i mean right sorry
right so i'm actually not i'm not sure
that
right so i guess this is just the
fluctuation so the bouncer of time are
actually sample dependent right it
depends
how many samples arrived at this
interval so we are not averaging right
so so there's some randomness in this
there's some randomness in the process
which you know depending on how many
events arrived at the interval and how
many coalescences actually took place
the the width of the interval will
change
right
there were more events somehow there
were more events of coalescence some are
randomly and that's the reasons that the
the interval was one that's a very good
point yeah
okay so let's look at another example i
mean this is i mean you could you can
just start if this is a because there's
both a jump and a more more or less more
smooth transition the population size
and that's the picture that you get so
it's a similar
so
so what did we get from that right so as
a statistician what we want to
understand is one of the things that you
want to understand is is the width of
the interval the right width of the
interval so what we said is that
essentially we can think about about the
switch if the interval
is of length epsilon
and as long as l is large enough then
the width of the confidence interval for
a fixed uh confidence level is going to
be epsilon inverse quantile it's going
to be order of one over square l
and
on the other hand you can show or we can
we can show that using the data that
we're talking about here you cannot see
smaller differences than that so let me
say what do i mean by that
so
let's look at a bunch of pairwise
coefficients time for population of size
n
and let's look at another bunch of id
pairwise scholars in time for a
population that's a little bigger so
these are
both of these populations are constant
size one is of size n and one one is of
size n times one plus a a is a small
number right think about one fixed
population and a little bigger
population and we have a picture here
so what do we know so okay maybe
everybody in here
everybody here knows what the total
variation distance is
steve knows that is there anybody why
you should go so the total variation
distance between the distribution tells
you what is the statistical distance
between them right so if the statistical
difference is small you cannot
distinguish between the two distribution
so what you can prove you can prove that
the total variation distance between the
coalescence time that you will get from
a population of size n and the
population of size n times one plus a is
order of what is order of the difference
the fractional difference of the
population size times square root of the
number of coalescence that you're seeing
okay so this square root here and the
square root will correspond exactly to
the square root here that we've seen
before right because in the in our model
we are looking when we're looking at
some deep interval we are looking at
only
those spells that haven't called us up
up to this time so this little n
actually corresponds to the big l so it
means that the width of the interval is
indeed the width of the interval is
indeed the order square right so sorry
so the conclusion here so here a is just
constant the population size is constant
right so in order to prove in order to
prove that what we're doing is optimal
it's enough for me to show one scenario
where you know you cannot do something
better than that and then once an hour
is very simple scenario i mean you can
think about this interval of some
interval way back in time so there's
some interval way back in time and i
promise you that this interval is going
to be either of the size of the initial
population or five percent more and i'm
telling you can you tell me if it's the
original size of five percent no and
this result tells you that if square
root l times a is much smaller than one
is approaching zero then you cannot do
better than random you cannot do better
than one half one half okay so that's
the setup here
so it means that at least in some sense
if you look at this at the width of the
interval the you know up to constants
and so on and so forth the procedure
that we presented is optimal so you
cannot do you cannot get a confidence
interval that's that's that's a smaller
than order square root of l one over
square root of five
okay any questions so far okay good
so here actually this is something that
i've never done i've never seen done in
papers but we decided to do in our paper
we actually do three things
one is the actual population so this is
again in blue
the the reds
uh sorry we
the red is our estimate and the black
are the two populations that we cannot
distinguish better than we say 95
percent probability so if we're this
fixed population or this fixed
population we cannot distinguish them
with probability with confidence higher
than 95 percent probability here it's
you know the intervals are shrinking and
chilling and what we're showing in
comparison is our actual estimate right
so this is just to give you a visual
view of what what are the results saying
okay
why does the black and the red bars not
uh
why are the black lines inside the bed
second bars are the black lines inside
the red bars
i would think if you could distinguish
the two with 95
confidence
then they should just be like a bar with
a part right so
the actual population side is here
right
and
i i cannot you know it should typically
be the case that the red bar is between
the black the black bar and the blue bar
but not always i think he means the
confidence interval the pink part
why is the pink bar in the black range
not the same not the same okay so right
okay so that's that's a very good
question so the pink vowels and the the
just because you know this this if you
want to talk about this one over hotel
this is where the constants come into
the play right so it's not the same
constant right so this this you know if
you look at this uh
these pink bars and the pinks bar are
some much bigger constants so you see a
very very big very big difference
between it right so there's a fact of
you know if you look at actual data you
know our bounds are not optimal in the
constant so you lose a factor of two or
three or four or five i don't know
exactly but you lose some factors thanks
but the black line is just
it's just for the red
the dark red
line should fall in between the black
lines no the black valley yeah maybe
okay so maybe the reason we haven't seen
this figure before is because it's
confusing
so there are four types of data on this
figure
the actual relationships from which we
generated the data that's the blue
there's what we estimated which is what
the red does the confidence the 95
percent confidence interval which is is
this pink bar think big about the
fifteen before
and
the other thing is that what our bands
are saying is that in order to
distinguish with probability better than
95 percent given the the amount of data
that we have here
we have the two population whose
distance is at least the distance
between the population here and the
population
this is the last result
in order to get a 95 percent confidence
you know it has to be you know the
population difference that we have to
have to exhibit is at least
the difference between the two black
populations if yeah we can talk after
the talk you know yeah there's a few
other things i want to say so uh
okay so
all right so
going back to you in question
uh
so what we really want is we want to
work with sequences
and i'll just summarize what we know
about this very quickly
i'll skip this slide and i'll skip this
slide and i say our bounds are not very
good in terms of you know if you look at
finance sequences what do you have to do
so when i talk about bonds i talk about
two directions one direction you know
maybe if you give me finite sequences
then i can apply standard tools and say
oh the the
the actual coalescence time is going to
be this interval is high probability
this is just estimating a binomial on
the variable so i can do that but it's
not clear we don't really understand how
does this affect our estimation
procedure and also our lower bounds when
you use a sequence data do not match the
upper bounds right now so i think the
one one interesting research direction
is to extend this kind of work when you
actually look at sequences and this is
actually something that i'm going to
talk in the second part of the talk for
this other problem
let me move to the second part of the
talk
uh
so this is what we've seen so far
so we have a simple method we understand
the bounds very well it's for idealized
data somehow
i think one very natural question is
what do you do when you have to we have
to work with finite sequences
and
of course it would be really nice if we
could work on real data so if we get
some finite blocks from some of you that
you believe in strongly enough and
you'll get
a coalescence time that are accurate
enough you'll be very happy to do that
so
let me at least mention in the last 10
minutes let me mention a work with
sebastian it actually does they miss the
sequences
so sebastian rocket is over here
and uh
so this is the question about uh
population threes versus gentiles
so who wants to hear about population
tills versus ginty so i mean in the
sense who haven't seen this before
okay so i have to say something about
popularity versus gentlemen so
so this is a speciation too for some
species but you know when you think
about the species there's actually some
thickness here that comes from the fact
that the actual populations here
and what can happen is that if you look
at a specific gene well this is the the
species tree when you look at the gene
tree what will happen is the coalescence
of the gene is going to to take place in
a different order right so in if you
look at this tree we have this spell and
then despair and then they miss over
here but if you look at the gently what
happened is that these three guys meet
first and then the other guy
joins them last right so some of the
genes and and the
and the species don't have exactly the
same thing and this this is a well-known
problem
and about maybe 10 years ago
dagnan collaborators noticed that
assuming that all the genes coming from
the same tree or taking something like
majority is not going to be a consistent
way of estimating that in this situation
so this is something that is known for
the way
so one thing that was also mentioned in
one of the talks so it's a very easy
observation but maybe we were the first
one to make it i don't know is that if
you
one estimator that you can take for the
distance between two population is you
can take the minimum over all the genes
of the distance or the the time of
divergence between the genes in in for
these two population so that's a very
natural estimate
and you can show that this is a
consistent estimator and you can even
show very simple upper bounds
so if you use this to build a tree i'm
assuming a molecular clock here what you
will get is that you will get the
probability of any error in the three
assuming that all the gentles are
correct which is again a strong
assumption the probability of error in
building the three is going to be at
miss at most the number of population
that you have
times something exponentially small in
the number of genes but how
exponentially small crucially depends on
c which is the shortest branch of the
tree
so some are shorter branches short
branches are very hard to detect we know
that's in phylogeny for many years but
it's the same phenomenon in population
genetics you have to somehow get to the
short branch in order to be able to
detect what's going on
okay so this is a result that we had
with sebastian about seven years ago
and interestingly in the paper we said
you should not use this in practice
because this is not very robust and then
a few years later people started showing
up saying we tried this in practice and
it doesn't work so you know we didn't
really know how to react to that because
the paper said you should not use this
in practice because this is not the
robot but anyway people were complaining
about it so and they didn't cite us for
this complaint because we complained
about it right they should have cited us
okay and there are many other
methods for linear sorting that people
develop after that they'll be at about
the same time so i won't go into that
let me just mention there is the result
that we have in sebastian so
what we know is that if we have
sufficiently many accurate gene trees
then we can reconstruct a population
tree
we also know just by standard arguments
assuming that the model is correct that
if the gene is long enough then the
genetics are accurate
and the question is how long you know
what how should we set up the parameters
in order for this to work
and what we proved very recently
actually essentially here at simon's
is we know everything right so we know
how everything scales
so if f is the length of the shortest
branch
then
in case the length of the sequences then
the number of genes that you need
is exactly given up to constant or
logarithmic was actually by the maximum
of maximum of one over the shortest
branch length and one over square with
the length of the sequence less time f
square so this is assuming standard
mutation models like duke's counter and
so on and so forth
okay so this is again related to the
question that you was asking for this
kind of model we don't know
the result just with the ideal uh
coalescence time so we can actually say
what what the results are in terms in
terms of the in terms of the sequences
that we need
so in in particular if
the the number of genes always have to
be at least one over the smallest
branches in order to get something
correctly and then the length of the
sequence that you need is this
expression which maybe is not completely
natural is is one over the sequence
number of sequences squared and one over
the
shortest branch list to the fourth power
so there are various
special cases you know especially the
two endpoints of the interval
where m is equal to one over f
and when k is equal to other one which
was this was one done before not before
so i'm not going to talk about that
so um
all right so i said already all of that
and
so i i was planning that if i have some
extra time uh i'll tell you what's the
intuition for what's going on so far the
paper is 25 pages i don't think i'll be
able to do it in two minutes so maybe
i'll stop here and i'm happy to take
more questions
let's draw the picture here
so you have this this very short you
have this very short branch here which
is of lens f
in summer i have to decide if these two
population meet first or this two
population meets first so in order to
distinguish this case i mean i have to
have enough events where the coalescence
actually occurred in this short interval
and i actually have to sort of i mean i
don't really know that it happened in
this interval right especially if i have
sequences i have to somehow my
statistical power has to be strong
enough in order to say well it's more
likely that in one scenario some of the
i'm not working the score lessons i'm
working with sequences the sequences
that i have indicate that they will
indeed have a little bit more
coalescence in this in this short
interval so that's somehow the other
scale how this gets to distinguish us
so in real life
you've got to break up your genome in
sufficiently large enough chunks that
the coalescent trees are independent of
each other or have different and trees
right so
so so there's less of a problem on the
length of the sequence but there is a
limit on the number of genes there are
actually in the genome for which you can
do this there's a limit on n right and
and have you any idea just in terms of
numbers whether this is
this actually could work
so i i think it could work in some
situation and probably doesn't work in
other situations
i think one thing one one lesson that i
would hope that some of you may take
from this lecture is is the lower bounds
right so it's also optimal so if one of
you is saying oh i'm reconstructing this
very beautiful specifically from this
data that is you know i have these
sequences of this lens and i ran my
message and i got something you know
this is what i'm saying you know you
cannot do it with confidence if you're
below the bound that we stated right of
course the other the other scenario is
also interesting i think in some
situations definitely people have
reconstructed the you know species tree
from from gentiles that seems very very
reliable to me right
if you run psmc on a data set then you
get like this posterior and decoding set
of
coalescence times it might be
interesting if like if you put those
into your method you could compare your
confidence intervals to like the runaway
behavior of psmc inferences and
like
see how close they get to your
theoretical lower bands
i'd be very very happy to talk about it
and if somebody does it like a
politician you know i really like that
people you know are considering this
kind of question and and
sort of gauge the gap between practice
and and and
you know what you actually use and we
can talk about that
no more questions
all right let's move on to our next
speaker
you